well over the last couple days there
have been massive crazy riots in Chicago
now you know about Chicago Chicago you
know like a dozen or so black people are
killed every weekend but nobody talks
about it because the shooters are black
and that doesn't really compute for CNN
or Washington Post or New York Times or
anything else and if you do bring it up
they somehow call you racist well
Chicago did do one decent thing for
about 27 seconds which was that they got
rid of far left lunatic Lori Lightfoot
but then 27 seconds later they elected
an even further left nut job and they
are now in an absolute state of chaos so
first off here is Lori Lightfoot now
former mayor Lori Lightfoot commenting
on the absolute Mayhem in Chicago over
the last couple days although she
doesn't quite think it's Mayhem
specific statement after a morning event
at the Chicago Public Library outgoing
mayor Lori Lightfoot was asked about the
Saturday night chaos downtown that led
to two people shot 15 arrested traffic
disrupted and the CTA suspending service
into the loop Lightfoot says there is
lots of opportunity to redirect young
people to Safe spaces but scoffed at one
reporter describing what happened as
quote Mayhem and here's the thing the
vast majority of the young people that
came downtown came downtown because it
was a great weather and an opportunity
to enjoy the city that's absolutely
entirely appropriate uh there are a few
that came with different intentions and
they have they have and they will be
dealt with but I'm not going to use your
language which I think is um wrong uh to
say that it's me and I am so sick of
these people gaslighting this you see
the videos of hundreds of young people
jumping on buses twerking in cops faces
breaking Windows rampaging through
Walmarts etc etc I'm not going to use
your language of Mayhem we're just going
to get lost in some linguistic nonsense
enough is enough first off I just want
to tell you if you live in Chicago leave
you must leave I'm sorry I know Wrigley
Field is cool I've been there all right
it's cool go there one more time and
then get the hell out you gotta go deep
dish pizza frankly not that great let's
get you a New York slice okay even in
Miami I would argue the pizza is better
than Chicago I know I'm gonna get a lot
of hate for that one but the chances
that you get shot while getting pizza in
Miami far less than if you were getting
pizza deep dish or otherwise wise in
Chicago but they Gaslight you right she
because of defunding the police and all
of the nonsense that she pushed she was
booted out of office they then elect
someone just as bad if not worse than
her then immediately you start getting
these rights and she's lost in whether
we can call it mayhem or not as they're
bawling people I mean there were some
other videos that were quite graphic uh
a white woman being attacked by about 50
black kids uh but uh you know again
that's not something you're going to see
on CNN tonight
[Music]
oh